[Applaus]
[Musik]
äthiopien und visual politik sind alte
bekannte denn äthiopien ist erlangt in
den wunder geschehen seit 2018
beobachten wir wie der neue präsident
ahmed das land zu einer vollwertigen
demokratie mit wachsender wirtschaft
formt ein friedensnobelpreis hat er
bereits in der tasche und visuell
politik hat in bereits zweimal zum
politiker des jahres gekürt also finde
ich da mit stellenabbau beiden doch all
diese begeisterung für abdi ahmed
verbucht wenn wir auf schlagzeilen wie
diese stoßen
[Musik]
äthiopiens premierminister taucht seinen
friedensnobelpreis gegen den bürgerkrieg
ein boom was für ein schlag ins gesicht
war an die hater wartet eine sekunde
bevor ihr euch auf die kommentare stürzt
die schulter aus einer erklärung und ja
meine schulden zahle ich immer zurück du
wirst mal sehen die dinge sind viel
komplizierter als sie erscheinen und
warum warum musste dieses äthiopische
wunder in einem bewaffneten konflikt
enden hat ahmed alle getäuscht und ist
der neue wohnort afrikas geworden heute
werden wir diese fragen beantworten aber
lasst uns zuerst ein blick auf die
geschichte werfen ein land 80 äthiopien
und iberia soll die einzigen
afrikanischen länder die die kolonisiert
wurden auch wenn er die neue zeit lang
von musulin ist italien besetzt war
aber glaubt mir in äthiopien braucht man
nicht die bösen europäischen
imperialisten um sich selbst jede menge
probleme zu schaffen denn es eine mehr
als 100 millionen einwohner lassen sich
in bis zu 80 verschiedenen ethnischen
gruppen unterteilen und all diese
ethnische gruppen kommen deswegen
miteinander auswahl kennen wie soll ich
sagen
sagen wir mal dass niemand die krone
distanzierung maßnahmen mehr gefeiert
hat als die äthiopier das einzige was
die äthiopier jahrzehnte lang
zusammengehalten hat ist die stärke der
macht der sie unterworfen war
unsere geschichte beginnt im jahr 1991
damals schlitterte äthiopien von einer
kommunistischen diktatur in eine andere
kommunistische diktatur und ihr redet
sagen wow was für eine tolle wende nun
die wahrheit ist dass es tatsächlich ein
radikaler wechsel war
[Musik]
von 1974 bis 99 wurde äthiopien vom berg
beherrscht einer brutalen militär unter
der berg war verantwortlich für die
berühmt-berüchtigten hungersnöte
äthiopiens in den 80er jahren das nicht
an michael jacksons song wurde
komponiert und geld für äthiopische
helfe einzusammeln in jenen jahren
starben mehr als eine million äthiopier
an hunger warum weil der berg eine
brutale kollektivierung von land
durchgeführt hat quasi die afrikanische
variante von stars oder massenmord in
der ukraine
1991 nach einem langen und blutigen
krieg wurden die berg von der macht
vertrieben und so wurde ein neues
äthiopien geboren in äthopien das einen
ähnlichen modell wie der chinesische
kommunismus folgen in der tat waren die
beziehungen zwischen china und äthiopien
immer sehr gut aber das ist eine andere
geschichte für ein separates video
die wahrheit ist dass unter allen
gruppen zwei hervor stachen auf der
einen seite war die eritreische wird in
ihrer gruppe welche die unabhängigkeit
ihres landes erreicht hatte auf der
anderen seite gab es die tplf de grey
people's liberation front die die grey
sind eine der 80 gegnerischen gruppen
äthiopiens sie leben im norden des
landes ganz in der nähe von eritrea
anstellen 6 prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung dar da sie jedoch
diejenigen waren die den dreck besiegten
wurden sie die herren des neuen etikett
tatsächlich regierte ihr anführer mehlis
der na'vi 17 jahre lang das ganze land
und du denkst du jetzt wahrscheinlich
aber was macht es für einen unterschied
welcher ethnischen gruppe dieser mann
angehört das spielt eine rolle es spielt
eine sehr große rolle denn in äthiopien
bedeutet mir alles
tatsächlich ist das britische parlament
nicht nur parteien sondern in ebenen
unterteilt mehr noch das ganze land ist
in neun regionen aufgeteilt diese
regionen werden kilic genannt im plural
oder kiel im singular nun die grenzen
dieser kinder werden nach ethnischen
kriterien gezogen
ein beispiel ist einer dieser klodt dort
gehören und 96 prozent der bevölkerung
zur ethnie der theke und seit jahren
wird die gesamte macht in äthiopien
zwischen die integra den nicht mit
leeren händen aus dem krieg hervor kamen
den rovers und den am fahrers welche die
mehrheit darstellen aufgeteilt und genau
hier liegt das problem denn der
derzeitige typische präsident gehört der
volksgruppe der roma tatsächlich wurde
er premierminister nur weil die am
fahrer in ihre unterstützung gaben und
das bedeutet dass die tigray ihren
ganzen einfluss im rest des landes
verloren haben also was geschah als
licht ist nur lasst uns darauf ein blick
[Musik]
das letzte gebrüll des tegra bin ahmed
kam im april 2018 an die macht hatte
zwei jahre zeit bis zu den nächsten
parlamentswahlen die mitte 2020
stattfinden sollte aber diese zwei jahre
erreicht mit vollkommen aus um das land
gehörig umzukrempeln
gleich zu beginn unterzeichnete ein
friedensabkommen mit eritrea mit dem
sich äthiopien seit fast 30 jahren im
krieg gefunden hatte aber das wichtigste
war dass alle gesetze aufruft welche den
medien zensieren und freie wahlen
angekündigt
mit anderen worten im gegensatz zu den
vorangegangenen wahlen sollten diese
nicht an hat eine show sein
die damit endete dass sowieso immer die
stammesführer den premierminister
bestimmt allerdings ist die
demokratisierung eines landes mit derart
vielen polarisierten ethnien kein
zuckerschlecken
[Musik]
äthiopiens premierminister ahmed
entlässt den stabschef der armee und den
direktor des geheimdienstes in einer
großen militärischen umwälzung proteste
gray äthiopiens verhaftet
regierungsbeamte wegen korruption
ehemalige äthiopischer minister wegen
korruption inhaftiert wie du bereits
sehen kann es besteht eine strategie
darin die von den djs an den 90er jahren
errichtet netzwerke der macht zu
beseitigen und diese strategie kam in
der region tigray natürlich nicht
besonders gut an
nach 30 jahren der dominanz in äthiopien
lässt ist nicht leicht zu akzeptieren
was man die macht abgeben muss putin
kohl merkel und andere dauer herrscher
können da sicher ein lied von sehen sie
versuchen ja immer wieder das
unvermeidliche hinauszuschieben bis zum
bitteren ende
die tigray zogen ihren letzten strohhalm
ende 2020 der führer der region tigray
der presse michael ist ihn uns der abi
ahmed herausgefordert hat
premierminister von äthiopien zu werden
er plante im jahr 2020 erneut bei den
wahlen anzutreten
die idee war dass diese wahl nicht nur
eine reine formalität sein würden sie
mussten frei sein in einem land
äthiopien bedeutet dies aber eine
volkszählung durchzuführen und eine
volkszählung einem armen land wird 100
millionen einwohnern umzusetzen ist
nicht einfach als ob das alles nicht
schon genug wäre hat corona die dinge
auch noch komplizierter gemacht also
schlug vor die wahl auf 2.021 zu
verschieben
tja und dann was ihr so dass
[Musik]
der äthiopische premierminister
verlängert amtszeit da war legen virus
verschoben wird
diego ist bestanden jedoch darauf dass
es legitim amtszeit im jahr 2020 endet
also forderten sie die föderale macht in
addis abeba heraus und kündigten an dass
sie ihre eigenen wahlen im september
abhalten würden ich sagte absichtlich
wahlen weil der brite michael dabei 98,2
prozent der stimmen bekam
komisch nicht wahr auch abdi ahmed ist
nicht untätig geblieben denn er
beschloss die bundesmittel für die
regierung tigray einfach zu kürzen als
druckmittel gegen die titel es doch die
eigentliche herausforderung kam dann im
oktober nachrichten region tigray sagt
dass sie sich über bundesgesetze
hinwegsetzen wird die ab dem 15 oktober
in kraft treten
bedenkt bitte die region tigray ist
diejenige mit den am besten gerüstet und
armee-einheiten das gegen eritrea kraft
abrupten örtliche kommando der
äthiopischen armee ist dort stationiert
und viele dort haben darauf spekuliert
dass diese soldaten im fall eines
bürgerkrieges gegen die zentralregierung
rebellieren können aber der point of no
return war der fürther november als tpms
kräfte die stützpunkte des mordkommandos
der bundes armee angriffen
die tplf versichert dass dieser angriff
nie stattgefunden hat und dass abdi
ahmed inszenierte um einen vorwand für
den einmarsch printy gray zu schaffen
eine ford flex ration also wer aber hat
unrecht nur was soll ich sagen
mal ganz abgesehen davon wer den ersten
schuss abgefeuert hat gibt es zwei dinge
welche die tplf sehr schlecht aussehen
lassen
das erste ist dass de grace eritrea mit
dem ziel bombardiert haben den konflikt
zu internationalisieren und andere
akteure wie zb die afrikanische union zu
eingreifen zu provozieren
denn nach drei jahrzehnten in dem sie
äthiopien im ausland vertreten haben
haben die tigers immer noch viele
freunde auf der internationalen bühne
wollt ihr ein beispiel habt ihr schon
mal von einem gewissen tetrasun umgeht
er jesus gehört
nun er ist kein geringerer als der
derzeitige generaldirektor der
weltgesundheitsorganisation bh und ist
ein ehemaliges mitglied der pls aber es
gibt noch einen zweiten grund das zu
verurteilen was die tigres getan haben
und das ist die ethnische säuberung die
koreanische jugendgruppe wird das
massaker sap entschuldigt
mehr als 600 zivilisten meister wurden
in my car der tot aufgefunden als bundes
ruppen in diese kleine stadt einzuholen
es handelt sich um ein gebiet in kiel
von tigray dass die aha als ihr eigenes
beanspruchen amnesty international hat
darauf hingewiesen dass es sich bei den
tätern um eine gruppe junger tigray
handelt am 28 november hatten die ahmed
nach der einnahme der hauptstadt von
tigray den sieg im krieg gegen die b-elf
verkündet die rebellen kräfte sind in
die berge geflüchtet und versichern dass
die apex weiterhin entgegen treten
werden dies scheint jedoch eher an die
bereits seitens der tpf zu sein denn es
handelt sich nicht mehr um jene jungen
dynamischen führer welche denen der
gestürzt haben sondern um eine gruppe
von 60 jährigen die sich weigern
anzuerkennen dass sie die macht schon
längst verloren haben
trotzdem hat abdi ahmed wichtige
herausforderungen vor sich der moment
der wahrheit es ist wahr die innere
krise äthiopier ist hat die hässlichsten
seite seines vaters zum vorschein
gebracht internet und telefonleitungen
sind in gebieten romero tigra gekappt
worden so dass man nicht sicher weiß was
dort eigentlich vor sich geht
außerdem gibt es zeugenaussagen die
kopten dass sich die regierungstruppen
bei der anwendung von gewalt wie der
maler selbst übertroffen haben
die menschenrechtsverletzungen sind
schrecklich aber zumindest ist zum
ersten mal ein äthiopischer herrscher
zur selbstkritik fähig schaut euch mal
die erklärung an dir in einem brief an
die econ ist 8
in anbetracht der institutionen wieder
geerbt haben ist uns klar dass
strafverfolgungs aktivitäten das risiko
von menschenrechtsverletzungen und
missbrauch mit sich bringt die
mentalität und die taktiken der
vergangenheit sind nicht so leicht zu
erlernen
sicherheits und justizreformen brauchen
zeit abdi ahmed premierminister von
äthiopien
okay es ist wahr dass politische
übergänge kompliziert sind zeit brauchen
aber wir müssen uns im klaren sein aber
die stunde der wahrheit ist gekommen
es ist zeit für ihn zu zeigen dass seine
versprechen auch richtig war denn bisher
hat es sich vor seine autoritäre seite
gezeigt er hat kaum einmal versucht mit
der opposition zu verhandeln drei wochen
lang haben die tplf kräfte den vormarsch
der bundesallee standgehalten nun da
diese bedrohung neutralisiert ist
mussawi ahmed zu seinem ursprünglichen
fahrplan zurückkehren
und das bedeutet die grey zur normalität
zurückzuführen etwas das im moment nicht
so passieren scheint da der kehle tigray
von der teilnahme an den nächsten wahlen
ausgeschlossen wurde
den dass die rare wahlbehörde hat
behauptet dass es dort jetzt eine
übergangsregierung gibt und dass die
noch einiges an arbeit vor sich habe
bevor wahlen abgehalten werden könnten
und das ist wohl nicht das schlimmste
problem mit ihnen sie sich
auseinandersetzen
technisches profiling von tigray
verschäft spannungen in äthiopien seit
dem ausdruck dieser krise gab es mehrere
berichte über ethnische diskriminierung
von tigris im ganzen land es wird
behauptet dass tigray beamte angewiesen
wurden nicht zur arbeit zu gehen und
mitglieder der libyschen
sicherheitskräfte
die dieser ethnischen gruppe angehören
entwaffnet wurden und es gibt nun mal
keine rechtfertigung für diese art von
revanchismus oder die ethnische
säuberung gegen diese bürger mit der
niederlage der titel sap ahmed seine
versprechen einhalten und ich bin sicher
dass es mehr als einen menschen gibt er
denkt dass diese abu ahmed am ende nicht
viel besser ist als die tk
aber wir müssen bedenken dass die drei
seit jahrzehnten eine enorme macht öl
haben und dass sie es den jetzigen
präsidenten eben nicht besonders leicht
gemacht haben tatsächlich erfüllt ahmed
in bezug auf die anderen volksgruppen
seine versprechen zum beispiel daran
werde ich euch erzählt haben dass das
selbstbestimmungsrecht der völker in
äthiopien der vergangenheit angehört
so war als jahrzehnte lang aber die
regierung von abu ahmed hat dieses
bestimmungsrecht erneut zugelassen und
erfolgreich umgesetzt
[Musik]
dass die dame referendum über 98 prozent
stimmen hört ja für äthiopiens zehnten
regional staat nur sieben monate nach
dem referendum war es bereits realität
äthiopien erhielt seine zehnte kiel
heißt das folgt das drama seine eigene
autonome region prostituierte und seine
autonomie erklärte und aufgepasst hätte
dies das vielleicht nicht dass letzterer
verhandlung sein es gibt bereits zehn
ethnische gruppen die um ein eigenes
autonomie der verhandlung gebeten haben
und ich weiß dass viele von euch jetzt
denken seit wann ist eine gute nachricht
wenn ein land an rassen grenzen entlang
geteilt ist und die wahrheit ist dass es
nicht einfach ist ein lang die tube zu
demokratisieren und im moment scheint
dies eben die realistische lösung zu
sein
äthiopische realpolitik geben aber die
frage ist nun an euch gerichtet
glaubt ihr dass diese referenten eine
gute lösung darstellen um die ethnische
spannungen abzubauen
denkt ihr dass abdi ahmed mit diesen
harten vorgehen gegen die quest richtig
liegt oder meint ihr dass am jahresende
auf bis zu politik zu einem jener
politiker gekürzt wird die uns 2090 am
meisten enttäuscht haben nun wie auch
mal
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat was ja gibt uns bitte an
neigt halten ohne folgen und vergesst
nicht unseren kanal zu abonnieren
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]